i've been fascinated with quantum
physics a very long time
so much so i did a phd in it and i
wanted to share the subject with you so
i made this map of quantum
physics to lay out the ideas within the
subject
to set some bounds on it so you know
it's not endless
and to introduce you to lots of concepts
if you're interested in them you can
you can dig deeper when you're
approaching a subject like this that's
so complicated it can be quite
challenging because you don't know where
to start and you don't know how the
concepts relate to each other so
hopefully this will put everything in
context okay first let's just look at
the geography of this map
to the north west we have the
foundations of quantum physics
and then traveling further south we go
through quantum phenomena
to quantum technology and in the south
and east we have the academic
disciplines of quantum physics
in the center quantum theory and in the
north and east the
the theoretical future of quantum
physics
beyond what we already know that is your
quantum forecast for this video
i've also made a poster of this
available so if that's of interest
check it out in the description below
and without
further ado let's get into it
the theory of quantum mechanics
developed from a set of mysteries in the
late 1800s and early 1900s
where reality didn't quite match the
models of physics at the time
we now call these older theories of
physics classical physics
there were several clues that pointed to
some deeper model
of reality when light shines through a
gas the gas absorbs and emits
specific frequencies of light which we
call atomic spectra
this was a mystery there was no known
classical explanation for this
and there was a lot of confusion about
how atoms could be stable
in classical physics the electrons
should continually radiate their energy
and collapse into the nucleus
the source of radioactivity was unknown
when you look at a hot body like the sun
it emits electromagnetic radiation in
many different frequencies and this
distribution of light is called black
body radiation
now the distribution we observe from
black bodies didn't match the
predictions from classical physics
and when you shine light on certain
metals you can make electrons fly off
this is called the photoelectric
effect this experiment showed that light
didn't behave like a wave but
like a stream of particles and was the
first indication of particle wave
duality
let's look at the foundations of quantum
mechanics the cornerstone experiment in
quantum mechanics is the double slit
experiment
where electrons are fired through two
thin slits and
make an interference pattern on a
detector behind
this interference pattern is something
you only see with waves
and this is more experimental evidence
for particle wave duality
in actual fact in the mathematics of
quantum mechanics all particles are
described as waves
by a thing called a wave function and
the way this wave evolves over time is
described by the famous schrodinger
equation
but we can never see these quantum waves
directly as all we ever detect are
particles but from the wave function we
can predict where the particles are
likely to turn up
but we have to do a bit of maths on them
first called the bourne rule
which derives a probability distribution
of where the particle might be
from the wave function so quantum
mechanics tells us that the universe is
fundamentally probabilistic we don't
know exactly where the particle will
turn up
the best we have is a probability of
where it will be
this brings us to the heisenberg
uncertainty principle which says that
quantum objects don't have
definite values for certain pairs of
properties for example position and
momentum
you can get a flavor of this from these
pictures the first is a snapshot where
the particle has a definite position but
we have no
information about its momentum which
means the direction it was going and how
fast it was traveling in that direction
the second picture has a motion blur
which tells us about its momentum
but now we've got an uncertainty about
where the particle was when we took
the picture another important equation
is the dirac equation which extends the
schrodinger equation
to include special relativity and
describe particles with high kinetic
energy
and another important foundational
concept is bell's theorem which proved
that the uncertainty in quantum
mechanics is not caused by our lack of
knowledge
about hidden variables but is a
fundamental part of the universe
this also led to the concept of
non-locality which will meet a little
later
finally we get to energy quantization
which is where objects like electrons
can only have certain definite energies
when they're in atoms
this is where the quantum in quantum
mechanics comes from and this
quantization is because their wave
functions can only vibrate
in certain specific ways you can see
this if i reduce the atom to one
dimension
the energy field of the proton in the
atom is represented by this bucket shape
you can think of the electron being
attracted to the proton and so it wants
to fall
into the bottom of the bucket but
because the electron is a wave
it can only exist in certain modes shown
here
which are just like the vibrational
modes of a guitar string
with the higher frequency modes having a
higher energy
this also means that quantum objects
always have a minimum amount of energy
known as the zero point
energy and this applies not only to
electrons in atoms
but to everything even to empty space
itself
now i understand that this is all quite
a lot to take in if you're new to this
but don't worry if all these terms are
confusing the point of this video is to
expose
you to a lot of the concepts in quantum
physics just so that you know that they
exist
i can't delve into everyone otherwise
would be here forever
but if you want to dig deeper into any
of these concepts i've made a playlist
of other videos that covers a lot of
them
there are however a lot of gaps and i'm
planning on filling them in in the
future
so if you want to make sure you don't
miss out consider subscribing to this
channel for more details in the future
okay let's carry on and take a look at
the interesting properties we see in
quantum systems with quantum phenomena
particles in quantum mechanics have many
properties i've already mentioned
position and momentum but there are many
others which i've listed here
spin is a very important property and
all particles are split into one of two
categories
bosons which have got an integer spin
and can all have the same quantum state
and fermions which have halve integer
spin
and can't have the same quantum state as
each other which is called the parolee
exclusion principle
superposition is a property when a
particle has a probability of being in
many different states for example two
different places at the same time
this simply means that its wave function
has values in two different places
although when you measure it it will
turn up in just one place
being in multiple places at once is
confusing if we think of particles but
it's completely natural when we think of
waves
for example any point on the surface of
the ocean is a superposition of
thousands of different waves all added
together
you may have heard of schrodinger's cat
which is a popular description of
superposition
although it's not very helpful because
it was originally designed to show how
absurd quantum mechanics seems
as cats can't be alive and dead at the
same time which is true but it's not
because superposition isn't real
we now know that large things like cats
lose their quantum behavior because of
decoherence
decoherence happens when a quantum
object interacts with an environment and
its quantum behavior is lost
to that environment decoherence is what
takes us from the quantum realm
to the world that we inhabit and you
break the coherence of quantum objects
when you make a measurement
entanglement is where the wave function
of two or more particles interact and
mix
causing them to become a single quantum
object
this means that the properties of the
different particles will be correlated
even if they are separated by a large
distance
this concept where the wave function
that describes a particle is spread far
away from the particle
is known as non-locality and is another
thing that doesn't happen in the world
that we experience
there are several other very interesting
phenomena which only happen in quantum
systems which include
quantum tunneling the ability for
particles to cross narrow barriers
because their wave function penetrates
through
superconductivity the ability for
electrons to move with zero resistance
at low temperatures
and super fluidity allowing fluids to
flow with zero viscosity
there's also the quantum hall effect
which is the quantization of conductance
in 2d materials
and the casimir effect which is an
attractive force of very short distances
caused by cutting out large quantum
waves
between two plates an important concept
when looking at the quantum behavior of
large systems of phase transitions from
one collective behavior to another
these are analogous to the transitions
between different phases of matter solid
liquid and gas
but in quantum phase transitions it's
not only temperature and pressure that
plays an important role it can also be
things like applied magnetic field
whenever we discover new interesting
behaviors in physics one of the first
questions is can we use this to develop
some new
interesting technology and there's a lot
of technology that we use every day
which takes advantage of the amazing
properties of quantum systems
lasers use a process called stimulated
emission to create beams of light with
many photons which all have the same
frequency and phase
atomic clocks keep incredibly accurate
time by using the frequency of light
from a very specific hyperfine
transition in cesium atoms
and are the basis of our global
positioning system
the band theory of solids describes the
energy levels of electrons in many
different solid materials
and it's the basis of the semiconductor
industry which has yielded many
different technologies like
solid state transistors so basically the
building block of every computer in the
world
leds which you're probably using to
watch this on
ccds used in every digital camera and
solar panels turning the energy of
sunlight into electricity
electron microscopes scanning tunneling
microscopes and atomic force microscopes
allow us to see objects we can't see
with optical microscopes
because they can see smaller than the
wavelength of visible light
to resolve objects like viruses or atoms
and magnetic resonance imaging
techniques are used in biology and
chemistry for example to look inside our
bodies
and these use giant superconducting
magnets to create large magnetic field
and the most sensitive magnetic sensors
in the world called superconducting
quantum
interference devices whose core
components are a loop of superconducting
wire
which contain an insulating gap called a
josephson junction
new technologies are being built and
improved in the world of quantum
information
quantum cryptography takes advantage of
entanglement to make communication which
is extremely secure and forms the basis
of the quantum internet
and quantum teleportation is the ability
to perfectly copy the quantum state of
an object from one location to another
quantum bits or qubits are the building
blocks of quantum computers
which use superposition and entanglement
to create states that are practically
impossible to simulate on a classical
computer
the challenge is to engineer large
groups of qubits that can stay coherent
for long enough to perform their
computations which is not
an easy task but the potential is huge
because their combined superposition
means that they can explore an
exponential number of states at the same
time
this puts them in a different complexity
class to the classical computers we use
every day
there are many exciting applications of
quantum computers but my favorite is
quantum simulation
the ability to simulate a quantum system
which would be amazing for things like
discovering new materials with entirely
new properties
or for solving computationally expensive
tasks in chemistry and biology like
protein folding
now let's move on to the fields of
quantum physics research these include
condensed matter physics quantum biology
cold atom physics
quantum chemistry nuclear physics
particle physics and theoretical physics
condensed metaphysics is the study of
large systems of many atoms in solid or
liquid form
and seeking to understand their
collective behavior on a quantum level
i've placed this here because condensed
matter physics covers a lot of these
other fields
and condensed matter theory describes
the quantum behavior of collections of
electrons
in solids which explains collective
behaviors like superconductivity
and the energy bands of semiconductors
there are many unsolved problems in
condensed matter physics for example we
still don't have a theoretical model
that explains how high temperature
superconductivity works
in a way the frontier of condensed
matter physics deals with complexity
because the subject studies complex
combinations of many atoms which make
many different materials with different
physical and electronic properties
the potential avenues for study are
basically endless
because the combinations are endless
quantum biology studies the role that
quantum mechanics has in biological
systems
there are many processes in biology that
are difficult to explain without quantum
mechanics being
invoked like the efficiency of energy
transport and photosynthesis
to magnetoreception in birds how our
sense of smell and sight work
and how enzymes speed up chemical
reactions
cold atom physics evolved from condensed
matter physics and studies gases which
are controlled in magnetic or optical
traps and cooled to ultra low
temperatures using laser cooling
and other cooling techniques cold atom
physics studies many exotic phases of
matter like bose-einstein condensates
and rydeberg matter
and looks at their behavior like quantum
phase transitions quantum spin systems
and many more cold atom experiments can
also be used as quantum simulators and
also quantum sensors like gravity
sensors
because quantum mechanics describes the
behavior of electrons in atoms it also
describes the basic rules of chemistry
the schrodinger equation is used to
describe electronic structure of atoms
and how molecules are bonded and move
called molecular dynamics
solving the quantum mechanics of
molecules is a very computationally
intensive task and so computational
techniques are very
important to quantum chemistry a popular
approach is a method called quantum
monte carlo
nuclear physics is the study of the
nucleus of the atom and the ways that
nuclei can
join in nuclear fusion or split apart in
nuclear fission and
also describes the particles and energy
involved in these nuclear reactions
applications of nuclear physics include
nuclear power nuclear weapons
nuclear medicine and techniques such as
mri
ion implantation and radiocarbon dating
particle physics evolved from nuclear
physics and is focused on understanding
what the fundamental particles of the
universe are
and how they interact experiments in
particle physics are performed in large
particle accelerators where high energy
particles are smashed together to make
new particles out of the collision
energy
this is why this field is also known as
high energy physics
the standard model of particle physics
describes all of the fundamental
particles we know
of which we've discovered over many
decades the last of which was the higgs
boson
a useful tool for visualizing particle
interactions refinement diagrams which
show what happens when particles collide
and they simplify the equations of
quantum field theory into much simpler
pictures
the theories of the standard model
include quantum electrodynamics which
describes the electromagnetic force
electro weak interactions which includes
the weak force
and quantum chromodynamics which also
describes the strong force
in the standard model these are all
quantum field theories
where particles are understood to be
excitations of quantum fields
which also govern how the particles
interact with each other
there may well be other particles out
there that we haven't discovered yet
people have proposed that dark matter
might be made of particles called weakly
interacting massive particles and the
large discrepancy between the weak force
and gravity known as the hierarchy
problem may be solved by
other particles called supersymmetric
particles
so the frontier of particle physics is
to try and work out new ways to explore
the landscape of potential particles of
very high energies
now onto the field of quantum theory
which although i've put it in this box
it really covers the whole map and has
specific implementations in each of the
fields
but here are some specific aspects of
quantum theory worth knowing about
the core of quantum physics are the
postulates of quantum mechanics that set
the ground rules
the path integral formulation of quantum
mechanics is a very elegant way of
calculating
the motion of particles by integrating
over every
possible path that the particle can take
and hilbert spaces are a useful tool to
describe all of the possible states of a
quantum system
in a giant multi-dimensional space
the symmetries of quantum mechanics are
an important part of the theory to tell
us the conservation rules which are
basically the rules of particle
interactions
what should come out of a particle
interaction based on what goes in
this is where we hit the limits of our
current knowledge of quantum physics but
there are two main areas of theoretical
work looking beyond the existing models
firstly the interpretations of quantum
mechanics are attempts to resolve the
counter-intuitive
implications of the wave function and
quantum gravity aims to reconcile
quantum field theory with general
relativity to make a grand
theory of everything the core of the
interpretations of quantum mechanics is
the measurement problem
when we make a measurement on a quantum
object its wave function suddenly
changes when we detect
the particle and the laws of quantum
mechanics don't contain any explanation
of what is
actually happening to the wave function
at the instant of measurement
we also don't know if the wave function
is actually real or not
and these conceptual problems in quantum
mechanics are what the interpretations
quantum mechanics
attempt to explain for many years the
default approach was the copenhagen
interpretation
but other popular interpretations
include pilot wave theory
the many worlds interpretation and
quantum bayesianism
as well as many others there's too much
to get into all of them but i've made
another video which covers this ground
they're called interpretations because
we don't yet have any experiments to
tell which ones are real and which ones
aren't
so really they're a collection of
interesting ideas rather than proper
physical theories quantum field theory
is the most comprehensive description of
reality we have combining quantum
mechanics with special relativity
but we know it's not a complete
description as it doesn't include
general relativity and gravity
there are many attempts to merge quantum
mechanics and general relativity into a
grand unified theory of everything
and the two main candidates are string
theory and loop
quantum gravity string theory is also
known as m
theory which is a theory that unites all
the different consistent versions of
string theory
it's very difficult to test the theories
of quantum gravity because you need to
go to such
high energies you'd need to build a
particle accelerator like the large
hadron collider but
the diameter of the solar system with
detectors the size of
jupiter so currently the best hope we
have of signatures of quantum gravity
are from observing high energy processes
in the universe
signatures from the big bang or black
holes which might give us some clues
and this is an active area of research
so that's it that's all of quantum
physics congratulations you've got to
the end
obviously this is a lot to take in so
don't worry if you didn't get it all at
the first pass but
you can always watch it again or grab
this image for a reference in the future
this part of the video was sponsored by
brilliant and if this video has made you
want to learn more about quantum physics
or get
better at maths and science in general
brilliant is a fantastic resource
it's a website with many courses where
you can learn and solve
problems at your own pace and they've
got a whole section dedicated to quantum
physics
and actively learning by solving
problems means that you can learn the
material a lot more thoroughly
than just watching videos because
nothing challenges your understanding
than a good question as i have found
many times
so this is a simple fun way to keep
learning more
if that sounds interesting go to
brilliant.org
dos or click on the link in the
description below
which helps me out because they know
that you've come from here and the first
200 people to do so will get a 20
discount off the annual subscription
which unlocks all of their premium
content
also as i mentioned at the beginning of
this video i'm selling this map as a
poster which you can find on my dftba
store
and if you'd like to support my work
i've got a patreon page
as well in any case i'll be here making
more videos aiming to make science
easier to understand so thanks again for
watching and i'll see you soon
you